[Musique]
bonsoir de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau 7,8 les invités voici les titres
nous recevons sur le plateau le
photographe frédéric grah les mots pour
toi remporté le week-end dernier entre
concours international de la
photographie à envier tôt en italie
nous ferons un point avec lui sur
l'événement et puis la parole à nora
fraysse la présidente de l'association
marion la main tendue elle était la
semaine dernière à la grande scène au
chesnay pour sensibiliser le public
voire scellement scolaire mais tout de
suite nous recevons sur le plateau le
photographe frédéric grah le week-end
dernier il a gagné le concours
international de la photographie
d'orvieto en italie il a remporté un
prix dans la catégorie sport grâce à ces
photos lors du championnat d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste au vélodrome
l'année dernière bonsoir bonsoir alors
ce prix que vous avez gagné vous êtes
heureux ça va qu'est ce que ça va
apporter de plus à votre
alors heureux oui ça c'est sûr parce
qu'en fait quand quand je fais du
travail personnel je fais une arrière
pensée aussi pour proposer mes images
justement sur à des concours extérieurs
donc en tendant un prix on est forcément
content vous ippon 6e l'articulant fait
se disait heureux seul celui là pas
spécialement mais je propose les images
en fait quand le quand ça s'y prête qui
a parce que c'est pas toujours une âme
concours donc là j'ai envoyé les images
à celui là qui qui se déroulait
justement en début d'année quoi c est
combien d'années déjà que vous y
participiez à ce concours
la première fois c'était en 2012
d'accord oui il doit là quand vous
faisiez vos photos vous aviez une
arrière pensée quand même voilà
ok très bien et alors racontez moi un
peu
l'histoire de ces de ces photos comment
ça s'est déroulé c'est au vélodrome
c'est ça oui c'est ça à cinquantaine en
fait l'histoire il ya quelques années en
arrière comme le vélodrome est sorti de
terre
on accueillir les championnats du monde
où j'ai assisté en tant que spectateur
et où j'ai déjà fait des photos mais des
tribunes cette fois ci et les les élèves
de la vie ont fait que j'ai rencontré
une personne qui s'appelle morgan
poulard qui travaille au vélodrome je
lui ai montré mes images et j'expose
j'expose d'ailleurs actuellement au
vélodrome avec ces images là depuis un
an
et c'est grâce à elle en fait que j'ai
pu avoir mon accréditation pour avoir
accès à la piste et faire des images un
peu différente qu'on plus compliqué à
faire quand on est dans les tribunes
quoi quand vous êtes arrivé vous aviez
déjà une idée en tête de ce que vous
souhaitiez ou en termes de photos où
c'est vraiment sur le moment annoncé
vraiment sur le moment parce qu'un sport
en fait on sait pas ce qui va arriver
peut-être un type de photos c'est le
néophyte qui parle
non là honnêtement après c'est en
fonction de ce qui se passe comme
compétition les champions font aussi les
photos c'est à dire que sans le dénigrer
personnes on n'aurait pas le même style
d'image avec des petits poussins qui
débute quoi voilà donc c'est vraiment du
reportage et
et puis ben regarder ce qui se passe
autour et avoir l'oeil quoi en terme de
vitesse
ça apporte quelque chose en plus à la
photo quand vous l'avez pris cette photo
vous ai dit si tu as quelque chose
alors justement là cela vous vous
rebondissez sur ce que je dis à quelques
milles par rapport au champion il ya une
dune des images qui a été primée qui a
une mention d'honneur où justement voit
l'effet de vitesse alors qu'on est sur
un sur un circuit qui tourne sa mise à
part les champions on peut pas réussir
quoi parce que les autres et non pas
assez vite et donc il y avait aussi
d'autres personnes en compétition vous
étiez sûr de vous moment vous avez donné
les photos c'est vraiment tombé comme ça
annoncé au nom cerveau on est sûr ouais
non c'est on a quand on participe on a
toujours se dit toujours
bref les images ne sont pas mal mais
comme on ne sait pas qui participe on
peut pas se dire c'est sûr c'est mieux
que le reste
donc c'est après uniquement quand il ya
les résultats que que là on se dit cette
fois ci c'est moi et une fois que vous
avez gagné le concours alors quels ont
été les retours qu'est ce qu'on vous ait
dit sur votre manière de faire de la
photo alors le la remise des prix
c'était samedi dernier
donc c'est encore tout frais je les
publier sur ma page facebook
ça fait de la publicité virale en fait
donc c'est toujours bon pour pour mon
entreprise et pour me faire connaître
et puis voilà puis les îles retour quand
les gens les voient sur mon blog et
cetera sont positifs quoi et vous
attendiez vous attend dès maintenant à
partir à l'international c'était un
concours international peut-être des
photos copacabana président new york qui
s'est en fait je vais peut être aussi
intrigué prétention que ça mais moi je
g1 je me tirais c c si on décroche les
jeux olympiques on va essayer d'être
photographe aux jeux olympiques ça je
pose un mois de vacances et je fais que
des photos aux jeux olympiques donc là
pour finir si j'entends bien vous
attendez vraiment qu'on est les jeux
olympiques ici je les attends depuis un
sacré bout tâches les attendent déjà en
2012 avec mon passé de sportif j'ai
participé à la coupe du monde du foot en
tant que volontaire aussi j'ai postulé
là alors si vous m'entendez penser à moi
à la ryder cup parce que je suis fou de
golf donc
donc voilà là aussi va y avoir le le
tirage au sort de volontaires pour
participer à cet événement planétaire
eh bien merci monsieur g derrière mercer
vous on passe avant tout autre sujet le
13 février 2013 marion fraysse mettez
fin à ses jours par pendaison
suite à du harcèlement à l'école et sur
le net depuis sa mère nora fraysse a
créé une association mario l'âme entendu
où elle se rend dans les établissements
et partagent avec les parents sur cette
problématique
une réunion s'est tenue la semaine
dernière à la grande scène au chesnay
nous l'avons interviewé fondatrice de
l'association
marion la main tendue malgré malgré tout
ce que vous avez déjà fait c'est ce soir
c'est une soirée qui reste importante
oui parce que pour la première fois et
c'était l'objet no 6 à terme de la
diffusion de ce téléfilm c'est que ça ne
devienne un objet pédagogique
donc je pense que c'est très courageux
que la ville du chesnay et décidé de
faire ça est de faire rencontrer les
habitants les citoyens pour parler de ce
phénomène de société puis dans la salle
ce qui est plutôt intéressant c'est
qu'on a des familles avec beaucoup de
jeunes enfants donc je me dis que après
le téléfilm qui est quand même difficile
c'est peut être aussi
l'objet de discussions dans la famille
au collège avec des amis et ça crée du
liant donc c'est bien puis après il ya
le débat donc on va pouvoir la far north
à la vie de catherine verdier qui est la
vice président de l'association avec son
éclairage de psychologues bertrand
gardette qui est au coeur du système
bancaire du réacteur puisqu'ils les cpe
et puis moi ben mon expérience
personnelle de l'association et puis
voilà retours terrain auprès des élèves
c'est bien je qu'est ce que parce que
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
faites passer comme message qu'est ce
que le public attendait de de ces
soirées alors je crois que c'est
qu'enfin on parle d'eux parce que
souvent les gens sont démunis sont pas
tous concernés mais ils sont tous
touchés par le phénomène
certains vous diront bah c'est pas mon
enfant mais moi même je l' ai vécu où
j'ai été borderline nous devons dire je
suis grand parents comment je vais
réagir face aux écrans géants un
faisceau d'indicés parce que vous croyez
qu'ils se passent telle ou telle chose
il faut lever les doutes
comment porter plainte qui contacter
c'est quoi le harcèlement voilà c'est
mettre des mots sur un phénomène qui
aujourd'hui un touché un élève sur dix
en france jusque là question comment ce
que vous définissez le harcèlement alors
pour moi le harcèlement c'est des
violences répétées
voilà dans le cadre de l'école donc des
violences physiques psychologiques
verbales mais par tout moyen donc par
les réseaux sociaux à l'intérieur de
l'école aux abords de l'école c'est
cette violence qui va créer une
souffrance mais il faut qu'ils aient la
répétition et surtout une
intentionnalité de nuire est vraiment
une volonté de faire souffrir l'autre
voilà c'est comme j'explique souvent aux
enfants comment on peut au début se
poser la question est ce que je suis
harcelé c1 ce que je suis dans une
situation de souffrance
oui ça veut dire qu'il se passe quelque
chose de pas normal qu'on est dans une
relation dominant dominé
ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas dans une
relation normale donc il ya quelque
chose d'anormal da symétrique et puis
par ailleurs il y a ce sentiment que les
choses arrivent par surprise pour la
victime mais ça veut dire qu'en face
tout a été orchestré
voilà est ce que vous faites vous une
différence à vis du harcèlement mais ce
que vous une gradation entre le cyber
harcèlement et le harcèlement à l'école
scolaire alors il faut savoir que ça
dépend de l'âge en dessous 9 ans
aujourd'hui il ya très peu de
cyber-harcèlement puisque les enfants a
priori ne sont pas sur les écrans donc
angers les écrans sens large internet
des applications mais c'est vrai que fin
de cm2 souvent le premier portable
arrive parfois plus tôt notamment pour
des raisons de sécurité quand les
parents sont à l'étranger ou parents
divorcés donc c'est un lien quand même
qu'ils restent donc il faut accompagner
l'enfant avec avec l'usagé du téléphone
portable
et puis plus jeunes aussi sont pas
forcément sur les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup jouent sur des
jeux vidéo en réseau donc ça peut être
au même titre qu'on va les informer sur
les prédateurs sexuels sur la drogue sur
les risques divers liés à leur âge il
faut les informer que c'est un bel outil
mais donc pour répondre à votre question
aujourd'hui à un ado est harcelé et
cyber harcelés et c'est rarement où
c'est souvent et est donc c'est harcelé
par ses pairs prs donc c'est ça qui est
compliqué pour les jeunes puisqu'il ya
une arme qui est mieux pour prévenir du
harcèlement non c'est le couteau suisse
qu'il faut dégainer
c'est à dire qu'il faut à la fois former
les enseignants les encadrant le
personnel qui est autour de l'enfant les
atsem dès la maternelle
les éducateurs sportifs le service
jeunesse il faut qu'ils aient des spots
à la télé faux qui est aujourd'hui un
enfant de 5 ans il va vous dire il faut
manger cinq fruits et légumes par jour
manger bouger
asaïs est il connaît la lutte contre
l'obésité mais sur ces tous ces sujets
là et personne en a conscience il faut
former les élèves à la bienveillance au
respect il faut pas que ce soit que des
mots faut aussi les mettre en pratique
donc il faut former toute la population
parce qu'on connaît mais pour alors
évidemment il ya des conséquences
tragiques comme mario mais moi je dis
souvent le harcèlement est pas une
fatalité on peut s'en sortir c'est ça le
message d'espoir donc il faut qu'on soit
tous formés comme quand on est formés
aux premiers secours et ben là c'est la
même
c'est du même ordre est ce qu'on peut
dire alors du coup que les couteaux
suisses mais ce que en termes de
prévention finalement c'est quoi c'est
le dialogue le plus un enfant qui veut
pas parler vous en tirerez rien de toute
façon vous dites 22 % des élèves n'en
parle pas et plus grandissement il en
parle parce que il ya d'abord la peur
puis à laon puis la peur des
représailles
puis tous ces enfants à qui on a dit
depuis la maternelle t'as qu'à te
défendre arrête de rapporter enfin vous
fait après c'est bien ancrée et des
élèves qui vise à procès ça que je le
dise on va pas me croire donc à la fois
une grandissent avec ce sentiment
d'injustice
donc je vous dis il faut vraiment où les
tous les acteurs de la société soit
formé également les médecins à déceler
catherine elle reçoit nombreux patients
sur ces sujets là qui viennent non pas
pour dire à mon avis je subi du
harcèlement mes phobies scolaires
troubles alimentaires conduites
addictives je pense que c'est quand on
commence à s'intéresser à ces sujets on
va résoudre beaucoup de problèmes sur la
délinquance le décrochage scolaire des
problèmes de santé de santé mentale on a
un vrai problème en france sur la
prévention d'une manière générale en
matière de santé publique
donc il reste tant à faire mais tant
qu'on n'aura pas vous disiez dans les
pays nordiques ou en angleterre
mais il ya une vraie prise de parole
des gouvernants il ya des moyens qui
sont déployés il ya un vrai budget
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de budget enfin
je veux dire on peut avoir toute la
bonne volonté du monde
malheureusement ça suffit pas c'est la
fin de ce set 8 les invités bonne soirée
à tous
[Musique]